[Music]
my name is Ryan Mulholland and I have
the privilege of serving on the
professional services team that is
dedicated to ensuring the success of our
state and local government customers
like New York City I've been engaged
with New York City Cyber Command since
December of 2017 and in that time I've
had the absolute privilege of working
with a dedicated team of New Yorkers
that are really focused on providing the
very best in cyber security for New York
and her residence in that time I've
watched as they built a new approach to
cybersecurity and one which I believe
will be the future of the way we all
look to cybersecurity in the future and
it's that dedicated team and their
efforts here today that we get to talk
about for the first time so it is my
pleasure to introduce to you to Colin
Hay Hearn today I'm pardon me Colin
Hearn he is the deputy chief information
officer leading security sciences for
New York City Cyber Command prior to
joining the cybersecurity effort in New
York City
Colin year pardon me Colin served for
seven years as an officer in the United
States Army where he served two tours in
Afghanistan and as commander of cyber of
a cyber space operations company after
serving in the army Colin worked in the
financial sector focused on security
engineering and cyber threat
intelligence in addition to degrees from
Tulane and NYU colin is certif is a
certified information security services
professional and a Google certified
professional data engineer along with
his wife and daughter Colin lives in the
bustling borough of Brooklyn do me a
favor please welcome
Colin Ahern to the stage deputy says Oh
for New York City Cyber Command
thank you thanks Ryan
so behind a simple idea is complex
engineering and when we started this
journey about 18 months ago our boss
Jeff Brown the chief information
security officer of the city of New York
threw down a gauntlet and that was to
construct a completely separate
responder environment that was
purpose-built to detect and respond to
cyber threats against city systems and
we call that system juggernaut and
behind a cool demo is a big team what
you see here is a product of multiple
teams all working together at New York
City Cyber Command throughout the
government of the city of New York and
throughout many of our vendor partners
like Google we think our approach is
instructive for those seeking to enhance
the way that they manage cybersecurity
relevant data approach technology
systems that are large and complex and
that they want to be resilient and
efficient and this is just one small
part of what we do at New York City
cyber command that we also
affectionately refer to as NYC 3 so if I
drop that little acronym during this
demo that's that's what it is and we
this is a joint effort with Google if
you saw just outside at the booth we
have a demo in the public sector area so
this is a joint effort and we wanted to
solve this problem at New York scale or
Google scale if you like and we wanted
to call this juggernaut because we know
there's gonna be roadblocks along the
way we know this is a long journey but
we know that we have the resources to
overcome those hurdles we also like the
juggernaut if you didn't know this is
British for a large heavy truck and we
think of our pipeline as a highway of
sorts so that that's kind of relevant so
this is what we're gonna cover today a
little bit about excuse me New York City
Star Command what we do I'll talk in
depth about the data pipeline and some
of the principles some of the key facts
I'll do a demo I'll talk about some key
decisions we made like zero touch
infrastructures code zero trust beyond
Corp model for context to where ACTRA
access
and I also talked about what we believe
to be the future of this space machine
learning and advanced automation and you
see there a pretty interesting fact 8.6
million that is the population just
within the five boroughs so not
including the larger New York metro area
which is about 20 million or even the
Northeast megalopolis which is many more
millions still and along with this large
metropolis is a large and complex IT
infrastructure we have 3/16 public IP
addresses that's about a hundred ninety
four thousand we have hundreds and
hundreds of web applications ranging
from an application residents can use to
see where their street is going to be
plowed to NYC gov one of the 500 most
visited web sites in the United States
so a very big complex infrastructure
that we defend so New York City cyber
commander NYC 3 doing right by New
Yorkers number one we're a new
government agency charged with defending
New York City in the city of New York
from cyber threats and providing tools
so that residents visitors and
businesses can lead safer lives online
we have a dedicated team of
cybersecurity and technology
professionals that monitor city systems
24/7 365 in collaboration with other
city agencies such as Department of
Information Technology and
telecommunications and other
stakeholders out of which our cities are
safe and resilient from cyber threats
and number three we believe that cyber
security is a public safety issue on
behalf of city government in this
administration we lead the NYC secure
initiative which is a policy position
that says cyber security is not only a
public safety issue but one in which
your government owes you something it
owes you actual tools that you can use
to lead safer digital lives we have
three tactics under this policy number
one is an enterprise-grade mobile threat
detection app called the NYC secure app
available on the iOS and Android apps
stores you can just or Google and myci
secure app and we believe that security
and privacy are not mutually exclusive
our mobile threat detection app does all
of its work
the mobile phone it doesn't send
anything outside of the phone it
collects no PII doesn't even have the
rights to PII on your mobile device
- we partnered with a nonprofit
organization called quad 9 which offers
free privacy respecting recursive DNS
filtering and we're rolling that out to
all free public Wi-Fi networks by the
end of this year and that's because we
believe that residents who use our Wi-Fi
should not be victimized as they do so
and number 3 those of you that saw in
the Wall Street Journal last Thursday
our agency and my boss Jeff Brown
partnered with the Manhattan da Sai
Vance and the Commissioner of the New
York City Police Department James
O'Neill on cyber critical services and
infrastructure it is a local
cybersecurity critical infrastructure
focused organization designed to break
down barriers between organizations at
across verticals and be selfish and
selfless and ruthless about defending
the city of New York against cyber
threats so very briefly that's the
executive order that created us in July
of 2017 executive order 28 signed by
Bill DeBlasio and broadly speaking we
wanted to undertake a very substantial
problem in a new way and we have three
goals at a high level one is build a
secure cloud-based security log
aggregation platform for city systems to
enable via this platform alerting
visualization and analytics for
cybersecurity professionals both
analytics that we had with existing
vendor partner relationships
capabilities that we might acquire in
the future and some capabilities that we
develop in-house and three and maybe
most philosophically we want to scale
nonlinearly with two kinds of demands or
two kinds of issues that we face number
one demand on city services that is
delivered by with and through technology
system grows every single day in
addition to 3/16 public IP addresses we
have over 400,000 workstation servers
and mobile devices that are city-owned
we have another half a million or so
connected devices ranging from water
meters to the GPS devices on the
snowplows that enable the app to tell
you when it's going to apply your street
so this is
that are really really really big and
complicated infrastructure and each one
of those devices in some way large or
small expands the threat surface and for
those of you that saw Mike Aiello's talk
yesterday we want to reduce that for
threat surface to a meaningfully small
area that we as defenders can interact
with and additionally the threats
against any one of those points
increases every single day five years
ago for you to take advantage of the
most advanced hacking tools allegedly
made available by the National Security
Agency and other governments around the
world you would have to work for those
agencies if those of you that remember
the eternal blue not petia wanna cry
these are leveraging alleged NSA type
capabilities and you could today right
now pull out your laptop and go to
github and have the power of the NSA so
that is a fundamentally categorically
different world than even three or five
years ago and we need to be able to
respond to that and we think that our
data pipeline does that to do that we
have a number of core beliefs one is
security the ability to do comprehensive
retrospective search on our security
telemetry in a separate environment
fundamentally changes the strategic
dynamic between us and our adversaries
it enables detection based on a variety
of sources with a variety of partners in
a secure way it can guide detection and
response efforts it can lead to faster
remediation and faster detection and
overtime allow us to leverage a key
asset our data in order to become
predictive and we'll talk about what we
think that's the case additionally we
want our confidence in the team
confidence in the tools and confidence
in the plan so we're obviously I spoke
about the incredible team we have in New
York City Cyber Command I'm going to
talk about just one of the tools we have
and going forward the future zero trust
networking our plan for fundamentally
changing the battle space with regards
to cyber threats to flexibility cyber
security is a team sport
we need a security product agnostic
environment that can allow multiple
tools to operate either concurrently or
in parallel we want to be able to test
add new capabilities remove them rapidly
we want to be data centric not product
centric and broadly speaking we want to
move from a request and response
framework to a publish and subscribed
framework and that's one that enables
the future things like machine learning
things like automation additionally we
need to build Federation and
multi-tenancy from the ground up we need
to leverage metadata we need to apply
this metadata so that we can be fast
this is a problem that has to be done at
machine machine speed not won at people
speed to data centric what is data
centric mean at some level it's about
decision advantage we want to provide
our network operators and defenders with
decision advantage over their adversary
because we want our defenders and
network operators to be able to know and
do more faster than the adversary and
you can't hire your way out of that
problem obviously it starts with a
fantastic team but that's not where it
ends it is about having the right data
to the right analysts or analytical
process at the right time with the right
context you need context not to
negatively impact business operations
and you can't do that without data that
is trusted reliable and verifiable so to
kind of restate that problem in a
slightly different way each and every
day we're asking IT professionals and
security teams to make decisions whether
to take an asset offline whether to
remove access to a system from some user
they are making a trade-off
they are reducing some risk which might
be present in a system or in the future
via the action of an adversary but
they're degrading the usability of that
system in some fundamental way we want
this process to happen as rapidly and
effectively as possible right time right
data right analysts and what we face
today is not just database access
insider threat sequel injection all
these other things it is the compilation
of the interaction of these forces
within a situation of extremely high
uncertainty if anybody's ever remediated
a security or a technical incident of
extreme complexity you know that
the incident first starts you can't even
be sure of what you know and what we're
demonstrating with this pipeline is that
we are removing we are systematically
removing uncertainty from these
decisions for our consumers our
consumers being the security operations
center professionals that 24/7 365
defend the city from cyber threats and
the network and in IT operations
professionals which run those systems
every single day
so as a extension of that metaphor we
need to systematically apply insight
people you know the term machine
learning and advanced automation people
don't actually want machine learning
they want learning they don't want
advanced automation they want the right
thing done as fast as possible so what
our platform enables is those workflows
to be systematically understood to be
programmatically applied and to be
repeated at scale and like all
organizations like all project of this
scale in complexity there's a number of
challenges one is the scale volume in
Federation as I intimated the city is an
organization of a it has over 330
thousand employees as I said four
hundred thousand endpoints a total of
about a million systems
there's a hundred agencies ranging from
the absolutely incredible Public Safety
professionals of the NYPD and FDNY
patrolling the streets every single day
to the mayor's office immigrant Affairs
doing absolutely critical cutting-edge
work in support of at-risk communities
50,000 police officers you know much
much much less than that immigration and
civil service professionals so that
scale volume in Federation makes it a
very large complex organization too as I
mentioned the threat surface and attack
surface is growing three I mentioned
white platform approaches for some for
an organization like ours are not
sufficient and while they might be
sufficient for some an entity of our
size and sophistication is never going
to be satisfied with a single vendor and
number four is technical debt the city
has been doing computers since the mid
60s the city has been offering services
to residents visitors and business
with mainframes since the days of the
IBM system/360 so this is an
organization which has a long and
storied history of using computing to
further the public good and that means
that we must approach our legacy systems
with data not wishful thinking again you
know how do we deal with more data more
formats and more locations more formats
and more data obviously I talked about
the admit you know all these systems I
mentioned throw off data large and small
more formats it's not just a syslog feed
over UDP anymore we have API based
access we have platform and software as
a service offerings that the city uses
and more locations the city has a hybrid
cloud strategy like many organizations
so it's not just on-premise data centers
it's not just one public cloud provider
it's all the above so with all that
really it's background our approach for
security data is one cloud native we are
built primarily on Apache beam and open
source data programming model and the
TLDR of Apache beam it is highly
parallel so it's fast and you can apply
the same data transformations both on
batch and in stream and what that means
is for a small dedicated growing
organization like ourselves we can spend
more time understating our data and
transforming it in a way that our
consumers were Funt will find meaningful
then on either running infrastructure
because we leverage cloud dataflow from
Google than on the deep technical
underpinnings of a data management model
itself to is zero trust zero touch we
believe that the beyond Corp
architecture obviously spearheaded by
Google and now embraced by others in the
beyond Corp Alliance announced yesterday
is the architecture of the future
briefly beyond corporate zero trust is
removing authorization and access
decisions from single points and making
them compilations of decisions either
about what you know about a user what
you know about a system or some
combination of the above and zero touch
you
infrastructures code enables us to scale
rapidly elastically and apply best
practices and we're not just security
professionals were also evangelists so
this is an opportunity through this
project to eat our own dog food with
regards to beyond Corp and zero touch
that we can bring to city agencies along
with the security outcomes we deliver to
our stakeholders number three modularity
it's a flexible architecture one of the
key differentiators is that this is a
publish and subscribe architecture
rather than a request and response so
that means we can take things out and
add them very rapidly the fact that we
combine this with infrastructures code
increases our velocity and our
reliability so that's all those are
things that are worth focusing on and
it's fast we intentionally built this to
be fast and I think the next slide I
actually have some of the metrics
because if it is fast you can apply
advanced things later but if it starts
out and it's not fast it is very hard to
make it fast later so we built it with
speed in mind obviously we use the best
technology the right open-source
projects the right architecture and
we'll talk about why that is but we
believe that to be this is a machine
speed problem not a human speed problem
so we want to count our our latency in
milliseconds and not seconds how many
milliseconds so we on the average day
process billions and billions of events
actually yesterday I think we process
slightly over 12 billion events and with
the average processing time is less than
10 milliseconds that's to do a now over
the next couple of slides I'll show you
all of the things we're doing in less
than 10 milliseconds and like I said
speed has a quality all its own because
you can deliver insights faster you can
apply later transformations at
incredible scale you can do things in
sequence that if you start out in you're
over some several seconds it's very hard
to make things fast later how fast it is
ten milliseconds it's about 50 times
faster than you blink your eye and it's
about if anybody remembers what analog
cameras looked like a one sixtieth
shutter
is about 10 milliseconds so pretty fast
so I want to spend just a couple of
minutes on our high-level diagram and
before I start this we are in the
process of writing a white paper and
open sourcing many of the not just the
architecture but the code we used to do
this so obviously feel free to take a
picture with your phone but over the
summer we're going to be open sourcing
this somewhere to follow and we view
this as the start of a discussion not
the end of a discussion and for those of
you that have seen some of these other
booths outside you'll recognize a lot of
these tools I want to start with number
one or a orienting you to my diagram on
the lower left we have an abstraction
for our on-premise data centers so I'm
going to start there starting from the
lower left where that one just appeared
we have log collectors and multiple data
centers we scaled them horizontally we
have internal load balancing and
additionally we apply beyond core
principles these are denied by default
these are control controlled by
programmatic regular key rotation via a
service account that communicate only be
a two-way SSL for four three over the
Internet they're accessible via a fully
qualified domain name internally and
externally you know things like this and
additionally we apply metadata one of
the key things about a publish and
subscribe framework like this is you
thou shalt apply metadata we apply
metadata about as many things as we can
think of and we also have a framework
that allows us to change the kinds of
metadata that we apply without
fundamentally we are connecting our
system or taking the system offline to
do that that's because we have this load
balance configuration and some of the
sre principles you probably heard about
in the five 9s lounge we apply
throughout this pipeline and two we have
what we call cloud to cloud data as I
said this city has a hybrid cloud
strategy so we via API and service
accounts using the same be on core
principles key rotation etc extract that
data via API from multiple public cloud
providers including Google including
others and that's because we want to
leverage the investments that the city
has made in these clouds to provide
cutting-edge services the residents and
in introduce them into our pipeline
and number three kind of the the middle
part of the slide we have a ingestion
front end it's a pub/sub as you know you
might have you could probably guess it
uses a topic in subscription schema this
topic in subscription schema is one that
is primarily used later in our pipeline
to parse and prepare logs for consumers
which I'll get to in a second and so
there's a front-end we call that ingest
right where to the left of the three and
what it does is it takes in data from
all of these places from our data
centers from our other public cloud
providers and it adds it to the right
topic it applies a little bit more
metadata and it passes it off to
something we call flow control flow
control is an Apache beam pipeline which
ensures that the data is in the right
format that the data is expected and
really it's a place that we can apply
metadata level automation and
normalization across this data without
in nerd speak deserializing these
packets and that's like I said because
we want it to be fast because we want
and because we use multiple concurrent
topics we want to be able to serve the
data as fast as our fastest consumer
wants to consume it rather than be
limited by as slow as our slowest
process so to do that that is why we
have to Apache beam subscriptions if you
will instead of one like some of the
other pipelines you might see around the
hall I also want to point your attention
to the there's a blue box which is our
primary and there's also a grey box
which is replica and so we have we rely
on google managed services which provide
a high level of reliability but we via
our infrastructures code and other
processes replicate this pipeline to
other geographic locations and that's to
ensure continuity and disaster recovery
and we don't quote operate two separate
infrastructures via infrastructures code
we simply tell Google put this over
there as well and I'll get into that
also at number four we have another
Apache beam pipeline which parses
and broadly speaking our consumers want
a variety of things
I mean consumers I mean analytical
processes and tools some analytical
processes and tools want data to be
normalized they just want you to make
sure it's AI they just want a well
formatted JSON message and they're happy
some of them want the data to be fully
indexed that you want it to be
transformed into a CSV or an Avro or
another type of message which has a high
structure others want the data to be
fully digitized so you might imagine
that those are some of those are
relatively straightforward to do and
some of those are not because we use
this publish and subscribe framework
because we have these two message buses
these two pub/sub you know sandwiches if
you will we can do that like I said and
serve our fastest customer now and our
quilt slowest customer at their own
speed and that is I think a key
differentiator with our architecture and
like I said that enables us to be fast
and stay fast number five we call this
the replicator we have a production and
development environment and importantly
about our development environment is
it's only there when we want it
obviously we're civil servants these are
taxpayer resources in addition to
effectiveness we need to be ruthlessly
efficient so we don't have a separate
development environment which is quote
sitting around winning us for waiting
for us to develop the infrastructure is
code we stand up a development
environment we want to push major
changes we want to do attack framework
testing when we want to test
integrations and other services things
like this and we do that via the
replicator we have a variety of projects
ongoing at any one time a variety of
stakeholders which want what we might
call rnd or non production level access
to our data and this replicator enables
us to take some all or some subset of
our production data put it to these
apply masking apply tokenization and
other processes without affecting these
downstream consumers and that allows us
to continue to apply best practices
beyond Corp type principles throughout
this production pipeline moving right
along
these are just some of the consumers
automation and orchestration dashboard
and alerting data warehouse I'm actually
going to during the demo I'll show you
bigquery
which we use for a data warehouse but
this is like I said just one small part
of a very large production system number
seven if you see is in the middle top
infrastructures code means that your
operators write software software
requires C ICD code repos and artifact
storage so we have that there's no
secret it's people writing software and
like anything
it requires maybe a change of
perspective or a change in the way your
operational teams might think of
themselves but we found that the
engineers and operators on our team have
really embraced this challenge so I
think that it is it is a journey that
certainly doesn't happen overnight but
one that we've been found to be very
successful and last but certainly not
least is we use the identity aware proxy
to broker access from users to all of
our production applications that means
that we have context-aware access with
user identity with device state with
other things and again this enables us
to get right data right analyst right
down so with that demo
and we switch the okay great so here we
have a number of virtual machine
instances actually this one is the booth
demo so I won't shut this down or Andrew
would be very sad and I'd be very sad so
this is the booth demo you see dataflow
is just virtual machines so there's no
secret again there's no secrets here
it's just virtual machines running java
but now I'll go to this live demo and
this is actually the same code that's in
the demo outside but instead of those
awesome buttons that you press for those
of you this unit I'm just going to press
buttons on a keyboard give it a sec just
to go to space and back okay great
so this is again the same button demo so
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
publish a Melissa a malicious message so
I published a Melissa malicious SSH log
and the last four digits of the message
ID are nine eight one six so remember
those numbers it'll those a tests later
and so these are all the data flow jobs
and there's two ways you can view this
one here all our data flow jobs to here
all the machines that are running those
data flow jobs but you see they are
things like third party SSH DNS so these
are data flow jobs that are subscribing
to our pub subtopics applying
transformation and auto magically giving
it to another pub sub topic which is
then writing it to bigquery so that's at
a high level what's going on and as we
move over to bigquery in a sec imagine
not just me on the console and bigquery
applying the sequel queries imagine this
were a unified framework with an
automation and orchestration harness
where these queries could be run
automatically via the bigquery API these
transformations could be applied and
rerun many times a day in parallel and
in sequence automation could be kicked
off both in this environment and within
other stakeholders environments so this
is a trivial demo to show you kind of
the power of a framework like this
additionally because we're using
bigquery and Google tools like this our
analysts actually mostly don't use the
bigquery UI most of them use Jupiter
notebooks ipython notebooks and things
like that to prototype within our
development environment which we then
the normal software development process
promote to production via our automation
and orchestration framework so all this
is preamble to maybe first we'll just
and this is just sequel again nothing
earth-shattering just select from our
demo and make sure that our message is
there
and you'll have to take my word for it
but it is the same message and you see
so time source IP source port
destination IP right failure so this for
example could be a malicious actor
attempting to ssh into a host that was
within our on-premise data center right
so let's say that it you know let's take
that as the example and again this would
probably not be in the context of a
bigquery UI this would be in the context
of an alerting dashboard and a response
process so obviously let's take a look
at this address the destination IP so we
receive an alert about someone trying to
do something bad to our host now let's
see what else is happening to this host
briefly so now we're just saying give me
all the ssh logs from our host ok so we
see a bunch of failures and i determine
which is a different kind of failure and
ssh logs undetermined we see a success
ok and i actually see a bunch of
failures within the recent time frame so
this is 308 302 so these are all
temporally relatively recent failure
success doesn't matter undetermined
interesting so let's say there's this
one 10 address which we see kind of a
bunch of failures from so now we have
understood
we received an alert someone's trying to
ssh into this system we look back let's
call it 10 minutes and we see a bunch of
other failures not from this initial
system but from other systems trying to
access the same system so this it could
be a brute-force ssh attempt that's what
this could be
now let's just filter by this one 10
address and maybe see if we can see
anything else going on
okay now all 22 22 22
okay failure they're all failures so now
I'm more convinced still that this is a
brute-force SSH attempt now let's see
we'd have just the SSH logs here let's
pivot from SSH to all the logs that we
have now for the purposes of this demo
we have DNS SSH web server logs but in
quote real life you might have a number
of different log sources that would
depend on how your use cases in your
threat management team or whatever your
processes are developed before the
purposes of this demo it's just it's
just a few okay so we see more of these
port 22 now we see a bunch of DNS so we
see 53 mail.google.com to design these
queries implement thresholds production
unit testing smoke testing again no
secrets
about how you know these processes would
have to be undertaken but let's say
brute forcing SSH against a jump server
where one of your use cases this might
be the kind of contextual quote advanced
automation you could do with a pipeline
like this so a lot of DNS is an SSH so
let's see other than this if they tried
to connect to anything else so now I'm
maybe I'm a human analysts I'm in my
ipython notebook I'm sitting and I say
okay I have my source IP I already know
there's a bunch of DNS an SSH so I'm
kind of done looking at DNS as a DNS and
SSH so let's look at other stuff okay so
now they have tried to connect to
something else and this is a brand new
system I didn't know about this system
before wasn't
it wasn't kind of organic to my alert
but I fitted from a brute force an SSH
alert that was decorated that was
enriched by our pipeline and data within
our debt with data within our data
warehouse I then served that to an
analyst who then applied human machine
learning human thinking and said I'm
interested in this alert let's see if
they turn connect to connect to anything
else and now I could do this whole
process again with this new indicator a
potential indicator of attack and again
I wouldn't necessarily have to run all
these queries again I could simply feed
this back into the system wait a couple
milliseconds for another decorated
contextual data element to appear to me
as a human analyst and on we go so
that's at the end of that demo and now
back to the slides you could switch back
to the other one okay great so zero
trust in zero touch I have just a couple
minutes before I want to leave some time
for questions and zero touch
infrastructure is code and how do we
deploy systems today as an organization
obviously the city is a hybrid cloud
provider it has like I said a long
history of computing excellence physical
data centers are here to say data
gravity is an important consideration
and how applications are designed and
architected were dedicated to ensuring
that those systems are also secure and
reliable but like I said we wanted to
implement a fully infrastructure as code
a fully zero touch application and that
means that we had to transition or
enhance our operational processes from
those of pure IT operations to
development operations DevOps and sre
principles that means that we have peer
review all codes are pushed to a central
repo reviewed by a select group audit
abilities 100% and our controls are
technically enforced so we have
obviously robust policy documents which
delineate who can make changes to what
but don't just take my word
for it we segment our environment by
project by repository and using
terraform and you know open-source di CD
tools we can technically enforce our
policies and again one of the principles
that I I saw and I read I responded to
is we don't want to blame people when
something fails we want to blame the
system so we wanted to construct a
system to allow people knowing that they
are fallible to receive the maximum
technical enforcement of our already
agreed upon principles as an engineering
culture and that means that you know and
some of those things started with
infrastructures code but they go to good
peer reviews they go to lunch and learns
they go to a robust blameless postmortem
culture and if you don't have these
principles and you don't technically
enforce these tools at least in our
experience it's easy to enhance a system
in which it is accepted that people are
human beings infallible and that we seek
to technically enforce things that we
all agree on rather than saying you
should be more careful and
infrastructures code again there's no
secrets this is actually part of the
code that runs the demo and you see that
these are if any of you use Kafka if you
haven't used cloud pub/sub and you have
used Kafka these look like Kafka topics
because these are cloud pub/sub topics
and that's basically what they are so we
ingest third party we do things flow
control so again secret is there's no
secret and again because we're using
infrastructures code because we have and
the documentation you know we might say
that if I write reviewing Andrews code
I'd say I would I want more
documentation on your code it's not
really clear to me what these variables
are well let's pretend that you know as
part of our code review we can ensure
that our infrastructure as code is well
documented because we're not at some
different point in time taking some
snapshot of our environment and then
documenting it this is the documentation
of our environment right here
the infrastructure of code and like I
said we have a full development and
testing environment we have
geographically redundant
components for critical systems and we
don't do that
by clicking a bunch of buttons we do
that by introducing variables into our
terraform code which is what this is
this is HCl and having the computer do
it for us and zero trusts and for those
of you that haven't heard about beyond
Corp or haven't read the white papers
from Forrester Research or by Google
themselves and Beyond Corp we removed
the trust in the network and place it in
what we know about the user the device
and the context our pipeline uses these
principles again throughout the pipeline
to ensure that our environment is secure
and because we believe that this is the
future way that applications will be
architected and again this isn't gonna
happen overnight the city has been a
city actually about a hundred and twenty
years longer than the United States of
America has been a country so the city
as an organization is one with a rich
history of transition and using
inflection points and we're confident
that the city is going to move in this
direction and we're excited to be a very
small part of that team of teams like I
said that's gonna do it but you have to
start someplace and for those you know
in the audience I I want to do
infrastructures code I want to try
beyond Corp this is a big important
application but it's one in which we
deliberately selected to apply both of
these principles not just because we
believe in those principles we think to
the future and we think they're
important but this was small enough to
be accomplishable but big enough to
matter and I think selecting the kind of
problem or project you as an
organization apply these you know
cutting-edge the next generation or
whatever you want to call it principles
for is important and moving right along
is another way of analogy because Game
of Thrones is restarting we wanted to
put a picture of a castle in and so the
analogy is simple we have a castle we
have old we have legacy we have all
these systems and we need to do two
things at once we need to chew bubblegum
and walk we need to embrace
next generation technologies and novel
approaches to solving problems while
ensuring that our existing systems are
robust and secure and since the adoption
of the internet many organizations have
tried and succeeded in doing this and we
think that our organization with the
help of Google and other partners is
going to succeed as well and that your
organization hopefully can to in the
future just a couple minutes machine
learning and advanced automation like I
said at the beginning people don't want
machine learning about learning and I
want advanced automation they want the
thing they want done to be done really
fast so a data centric automation
focused approach like that you saw here
enables that and centaur chess what
we're our vision for what we want to do
isn't to hire a bunch of robots to
replace a bunch of people that's never
gonna happen
we want to do and if you never heard of
centaur chest it's a person unperson or
a person machine team a computer applies
the strategy and tactics of its human
operator so using a person to think
strategically to draw analogy to make
plans and designs and then having a
system execute those at high velocity
high reliability and high scale that's
what we're trying to do training machine
learning pun intended people and
machines to work together and last but
not least key takeaways one the benefit
of using the public cloud for this
purpose scalability performance
efficiency and the ability to technology
leapfrog that we selected a brand-new
application that was important executive
sponsorship big impact and we we thought
to apply these principles on purpose
to our approach zero trust zero touch
and the power of data which broadly
speaking one of the primary the first
things we did was robust retrospective
search but that's just the beginning
and number three enable the future today
with automation machine learning
published and subscribed frameworks and
number four not on the slide white paper
coming this summer hopefully we start a
conversation with all of you follow us
on Twitter nearly every command
about any of this we have a contact
email up there and for any information
about our office about us but what we do
about our programs nyc.gov slash cyber
that's that's it
[Applause]
[Music]